こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん最近、星見ましたか？
星が見たいんですよ僕
綺麗な星 プラネタリウムとか家の近に無いし、
なんかこういうこういう双眼鏡とか持っていないんで
外とか出ても夜寒いじゃないですか
どうやったら 星 が 見える か な と 思っ た 時 に こちら ギャラクシーライト
室内用スタープロジェクター と いう ものがあります　もう まさに まさに も なん か こう　置いてパーっとやったら
部屋中星 だらけになるみたいなやつですね
もうシンプルに考えると、これを使えば部屋の中 でも星が見れるんじゃな かと思いまして、買ってみ ました 開けてみましょう
え、こんな小さいの？
うわーでもなんかわかりやすそうですね
えーでもUSBケーブルは何に使うの？
えぇ。。。？
ワァ！！ハァ！ハァ！！！ハァ！！！
あ、大丈夫だ大丈夫だok
フィルムを入れて正解だな
これでいいのね　これでいいのね　おっけおっけけ　これでもういいらしいです
で、あとはもう、電池入れればいいんじゃね？
やったー　簡単だ！
でもなんか星見るやつだから、なんかすげー難しいのかなとか思っていたんすけど、思ったより簡単そうっすね
で、電池3も入れて
電気を　消しましょう
（パチン）　んしょー
つけまーす
（ピキッ）
あっ。。。あっ。。。あっ。。。
あ、まっって　伝わるかな
なんか2種類ありますねぇ
パリピモードのやつとふつーのやつが
おおーすげー
わかるかなー
なかなかねーそっちからじゃ分かりずらいとは思うんですけど
ちなみにパリピモードにしてみますか
天井が激しすぎるのなんの。。。
ﾍｲｯ⤴︎ﾍｲｯ⤴︎ﾍｲｯ⤴︎ﾍｲｯ⤴︎ﾍｲｯ⤴︎ﾍｲｯ⤴︎ﾍｲｯ⤴︎
はい　ということでつたわりますでしょうか？
多分これねー　パリピモードじゃない方がふつーに綺麗なんすよねー
こう いう 感じ で 部屋 中 が 星空 に できる わけ で ござい ます
ﾗｲﾄｩ　ｵﾌｯ
ここ で 僕思ったんです けど 若干
弱い なっ て 思っ た ん です よ ね 光 が なんかうっすらとうっすらと星とかがキラキラしてるぐらいだったんで
これもっと　もおっーーーーーーっと
たくさん の 星を壁中につけまっくたらめちゃくちゃ
ロマンチックなんじゃ無いかと思いまして
今回、このおうち用プロジェクターを
たくさん準備しました
（パチン）ハーーー！！！！
これだけたくさんのプロジェクター が あれ ば
より幻想的で美しい部屋になるんじゃないか
と思いまして
今日はとても綺麗な動画ですよ皆さんに最高に美しい
ロマンチックな星空を見せ て あげようと 思い ます
ﾃﾞﾊｲｺﾞｯｯ!!!!
作っていきます！
電池！！！
できまし た この 部屋 は さぞ
（ﾄﾞﾔｯ）
置き方を工夫しなきゃね★ちゃんと置かないと多分…
綺麗な星にはなんないんで。
なんで ちょっと 綺麗 な 円 を 描く 感じ で
セット し て いき ましょう
はい、とういうことなので早速、すべて に、光をと灯していきましょう
まずはパリピ ボードではなく普通にあの綺麗に光の方でやっています。
スイッチ…
ＯＮ！×9
フフフフ…
ただまだ、わかいない。
でも、いいですねもうすでにちょっとし光を
感じるんですけども、 部屋を暗くしたら、この部屋は
どうなるのでしょうか？
おっ×3
うーん まあまあ綺麗ですね…
綺麗だけどもな～
何か、★じゃないんだよな
ちょっと ぐるーっと部屋を見回してみましょう。
そうだよな～。
えっ？！
はい、というわけで上 から見るとこんな感じです
若干、明るいくらいなんですよね実際。
いや、でも綺麗ならなんかすごい壁がね散り散りに光っている感じではありますね。
大事 な の は ここ からだぁ
次はもう全部パリピモードで部屋で
光らせてみましょう！こっち が 本番 ですよ。
この数の光具合といわれたらもうパリピモード待ったなしってことですよ。
ｏｎ×９
では早速パリピモードの部屋を 光らせてみましょう！
俺がするんだけどさ。
いきます！
はい！
ｗｗｗ
おいおい…
ｍｅ　ｍｅ　ｍｅ　ｍｅ　ｍｅ　ｍｅ　ｍｅ　ｍｅ
me me me me